the earthquakes That Shook turkey and
Syria this month killing thousands have
fractured the country's transport
networks the 7.8 magnitude earthquake
destroyed roads and collapsed buildings
onto roads rendering some routes
impassable and effectively rewriting the
map for some cities overnight that's
made it harder for rescue workers to get
Aid in and the injured out but now Aid
workers have a number of technological
tools at their disposal to find New
Paths through the rubble here's how
mapping technology could help the rescue
efforts in turkey and Syria
firstly there's drones
it might seem obvious but drones can
instantly give those on the ground a
real-time bird's eye view of a disaster
site helping Aid workers identify the
safest or easiest route through
obstacles and informing them of which
paths are completely impassable the
visuals can also be used to help
Rescuers identify areas that might not
have been searched and even potentially
spot signs of life among the wreckage
what's more they can be deployed to try
and assess the structural Integrity of a
building giving Rescuers an indication
of whether it might be safe to proceed
Spain has said it is sending drones to
Turkey as part of its Aid package but to
get a bigger picture of how road
infrastructure might have been damaged
by a quake you need to go higher much
higher enter Copernicus the Copernicus
program is the European Union's eyes on
planet Earth and is funded by the union
to monitor things like floods lava flows
wildfires and earthquakes in addition to
their own senses the group sources high
resolution satellite images from
companies like Airbus maxar and Planet
labs and combines them them with data
and Analysis to create a new map of a
region in under two days see mere hours
after the turkey Syria earthquake struck
the Red Cross activated the European
Union's emergency mapping service and
Copernicus began analyzing satellite
images of affected areas through a
combination of algorithms and human
analysis the group has been able to
identify roads that have been destroyed
and buildings that have collapsed that
open source information is then
published for all to see and updated
regularly giving rescue workers a fresh
map of their surroundings but what if
you could predict which areas of a city
were most likely to be cut off in the
event of an earthquake so you could
reinforce those areas to try and make
sure they remained connected well that
modeling tool is exactly what
engineering researchers Dr gionbion and
Professor Dina dayala have tried to
develop the Pair worked with Istanbul's
Metropolitan municipality to develop a
model for evaluating which areas are
most at risk of being cut off in the
event of an earthquake to do this they
took data on things like building
density seismic strength vehicle
throughput and Road layout to create a
heat map which not only shows which
roads and buildings might be damaged in
a quake but also which roads might
become blocked if a building collapsed
and crucially which areas were most at
risk from being entirely cut off in the
event of an earthquake the research
could also be used to show where
investment could increase resilience
against Earthquakes essentially whether
it would be a better investment to
strengthen a building or strengthen the
road or add more connectivity to an area
now the study was only published last
year and the researchers tell me it
takes a lot of granular data in order
for the model to work but in the future
it could potentially be a tool that
cities use to try and keep a path clear
in the event of an earthquake
[Music]